all right boys it's [__] here it's
finally time we're releasing the most
anticipated episode maybe Ever the full
sun podcast the long last episode with
Schultz we're here on Twitter because
Steve's actually in this episode as well
and he cannot be on YouTube even if we
blur his face this episode was filmed
November 10th 2022. so this was a
[__] long ass time ago this episode
was filmed guys but with this one it was
kind of I think our first time having a
comedian on we kind of wanted to treat
it like our boys only episodes where
it's our internals and we kind of just
chill and [__] throw down and like
talk about whatever's going on in the
world and we thought that would be a
good way to do Shoals we saw his video
and I guess he felt like we were asking
him generic questions or like we weren't
kind of we didn't know anything about
him which I understand his point of view
and guys I'm not claiming to be the
[__] next Larry King or [__] Joe
Rogan I've never claimed to be the best
podcaster this was eight months ago but
even till this day still like this whole
podcast thing we were kind of just
having fun with it and it got really
huge and we're always trying to get
better at it but with that being said
we've done so many different guests huge
guests we've had Elon on he sat for it
with us for four hours and he tweeted
after and said he had a good [__]
time Trump came on once and then
literally told everyone around him told
Dana he had such a good time that we got
him on again we've had Shaq like so many
big names and like this is our first
time where I guess like didn't enjoy
themselves on the podcast which honestly
it sucks for me to like hear that
because we obviously want every guest to
have a good time and we definitely like
you know we were excited to have shells
on I think he's [__] hilarious he's
obviously a legend now we've seen shells
said in his video that he didn't want to
put it the episode out because he
thought it was so bad that's what he
originally told me I was kind of the one
pushing to release it because I thought
it was [__] hilarious and I think you
guys will find it entertaining
regardless if it's bad or not it's
[__] hilarious it's a [__] podcast
like it's not that [__] serious to me
and then steiny didn't want it out
because Shoals went [__] with flame
on him I do feel a little bad for steiny
because I saw scholes say that he
thought Sonny was trying to troll him
and I don't think steiny was trying to
troll him at all I actually think steiny
was trying his genuine best to like help
keep the podcast going he did get
roasted pretty hard by shawls but I
think he was trying his best honestly
after Sean saw us talk about it we were
talking in a group chat literally about
doing it and then I saw him just post on
his story say release the Pod so I was
like okay I thought we were reshooting
it but I guess we're not I guess we're
releasing it I wanted to release it the
whole time I'd never gave two [__]
shits if it came out or not I think it's
[__] hilarious I think you guys will
love it Charles says it's our worst
podcast but I think it's our best I'm
claiming this right now the best full
sun podcast episode ever you guys let me
know what you think it's [__]
entertaining Schultz I think we gotta
run it back after this one we have to we
have to we have to the People Want it I
don't know life is [__] stupid then
let's get into it boys
[Applause]
[Music]
anyone now come on now three one
whole week our drive I gotta take a
[__]
leakage
nice to meet you
Andrew Schultz
um all right here we are New York City
Steve you want to put the mic in front
of you sure foreign
Brad's not here so uh episode's not
gonna be all about him it's a Groupon
Brad's gonna be pissed he's not on this
episode
you guys cool or what do you want Steve
something you want to talk about it you
wanna I think we should talk about the
100 fight we had yeah
um so we were at Ferrari World in Abu
Dhabi right you were there I was there
so I don't I know I
I paid or Brad paid for me and Selena or
something yeah with the idea that you
were gonna pay for Jacob yeah and this
is a hundred dollars U.S basically I
showed up late to Ferrari World so yeah
and there's a huge argument going on and
the camera's out so I'm like this is
funny like Brad's freaking out and so
Brad had actually pissed though no he's
like pressing me like he called out
Steve and was like where's my [__]
money and I thought yo this is for the
camera he's like give Jacob a hundred
dollars what was he kidding or was he
action you can tell when Brad's actually
because his eyes are like he's like
looking down and [__] like and his veins
are coming out but he's like being the
bully like using his size like yeah
give him a hundred dollars right now and
I was in shock did you call him out
what did I say I forgot you're like dude
you know how much [__] money I've
spent on you and your filmer which is
true yeah I was like I've spent more
money on Jacob than you do probably
just in general I'll give you the
hundred dollars but this is like insane
yeah I mean I'm not gonna lie so did you
tell him like yo bro I paid for so much
of your [__] like why are you pressing
me over 100. yeah and what'd he say
uh he was fired up when that guy gets
heated he stays in that heater what do
you say that what's the response to that
do you remember the response I know he
he didn't make me give the hundred
dollars after but it was just crazy
because it's like he wanted to like
beat me up for over a hundred dollars
Brad brought me McDonald's breakfast and
Abu Dhabi once no way I swear to God
free of charge I was surprised that's
crazy though because like we were both
standing there and then like I just kind
of like I just kind of waited it out and
I made him pay for breakfast no he's
insane
he bought me an egg McMuffin what that
was like six bucks you're taking the
biggest win out of anybody I know that's
pretty crazy yeah right venmo request is
coming but yeah
so we got Andrew Schultz today
you know that is that is cheap as [__]
though that's the cheapest like he goes
to dinner with us like you weren't there
but Red Rock and him and his other get
steak dinners he expects that I pay for
it I want to see him like it's like
crazy that he even chips in for his his
Filmer
I want to see how his ordering changes
be like yo let's chop it up
yeah right no I mean
like that's what you've got to do though
like like we all take turns grabbing the
bill and [__] and I feel like we're fair
but if someone's like that's not
grabbing the bill ever like chop it up
I'm just so used like Brad's Brad is
Rich like he's so I'm just so used to
like all my friends that have money and
just like okay you got it I got it just
yeah what goes around comes right it's
just how it goes so it's like that's
when you're but that's when you do that
if I notice that someone's like not
paying all the time or they're like
taking advantage of me then I'll be like
yo I won't grab the bill like I will
just be like yo I'm chopping it like
let's chop it up have you had to do that
before
it's not not like nothing serious but I
do it when it's necessary because like
you don't want to be taken advantage of
I feel right yeah yeah so then I text
him after it's like yo put the mic in
for me and I text him after like
I really don't appreciate you coming at
me like that like don't do that again
I've spent more money on you than your
own parents
and more money on Jacob okay I'm gonna
expose Brad real quick I'm gonna expose
him
this is gonna be like why are we doing
this the one episode he's not no I'm
really scared this was good this isn't
going out soon right now he's going out
next he has my watch I left it at his
place and I'm I'm seriously I haven't
gone it back for three weeks I think
he's stealing it but he probably is we
went to Vegas one time and uh we were on
a party bus and we were filming and we
had a couple strippers and we threw
probably Steve through probably like 2K
once and we go to his house a week later
and we got off the party bus before him
there's ones everywhere we go to the
house a week later and in the corner
there's two [__] plastic bags filled
with ones
and we're like yo what the [__] is that
from and Jacob just starts kind of
shaking his head and I'm like did you
guys pick those up from the party bus
because we like left him as a tip for
the driver
once
you made Jacob do that or you did it he
was like yo [__] this and they both are
picking him up and they're just sitting
in his living room and he you remember
this he's like yo I meant to give them
back to you bro I got them because I
didn't want you to throw them
no I remember him returning thousands of
dollars in ones but I remember the party
above well that's where we threw him but
yeah it was it was pretty crazy but to
be clear if Brad was here I'd be saying
this right now I'm not just saying it
okay if he was here I would not be
saying any of this no because the only
response is I have Apple pay yeah that's
his only response
is like made to lose your wallet I've
lost my wallet from them before but but
yeah I haven't talked to him since then
so so you guys aren't cool right now no
we're cool it just run me the wrong way
yeah
I don't I I would love to see his
response to that it's just like right
here 100 no he was just pissed off that
that Jacob wasn't able to get the camera
and
and took it out on me but it's like I
mean you could have some common sense
coming after me
what'd you say release the beast put him
in a group chat with Mary Beth
I think someone told my mom I told
someone I think they told my mom yeah
what's going on let's go what's good you
good yeah I'm good man I've been trying
to do this for a minute yeah I know
right Andrew Schultz was there a spot or
something are we going yeah we're going
I know I know Cole man
I didn't set this up you guys did but
obviously but Cole owns this place so
what's good where'd you come from
uh I've lived down the block where are
we Lower East Side yeah we're in uh or
Soho they call this area you lived here
your whole life no I grew up in the East
Village
now you're here with uh your wife yeah
my wife and I live down in uh
so how is this [__] I just want to say
talk to me man the infamous special was
fantastic oh thank you so much thank you
I bought it I made sure to share it
because you did share it it was
incredible thank you it really was thank
you man bro the whole marketing of that
[__] was like it was really viral thank
you man yeah was that like planned or
was that just like talk us through that
what happened with that oh you're saying
like when they won its edit the jokes
because didn't you want to sell it well
originally yeah yeah it originally was
with one of the streamers and then you
know they had some higher-ups there I
had some issues with the jokes and then
you know they said that they want to cut
the jokes and then
um I didn't want to do that
and um but I wasn't necessarily upset
because I knew that that story is like
perfect and everything is story
especially nowadays like I feel like
that's happening to [__] everybody
yeah yeah we're able to say which ones
you were like pitching it to no because
like the thing I learned about it was
already with one
so they they just they just were like
now we can't do that and the best thing
I learned about Hollywood is everybody's
just trying to keep their job
and like when you realize that like I
used to think Hollywood was this there
was like a few people that would like
come together every year and they'd be
like all right we can't do this we can't
do this exactly everybody's trans now
you know and it's like
that's not how it works it basically is
a bunch of people who are scared they're
not going to be able to have their jobs
anymore that's what I always say too
yeah so when you're terrified you lean
towards the safest thing which is
everybody we accept everything right and
um and yeah once I understood that I was
like oh that's not that bad these people
got kids and [__] is there ever anything
where you're like yo this is too far I
can't talk about this yeah maybe but
then I just find a way to talk about it
because it's all how you talk about it
how do you decide that I mean that's
something we deal with too but it's
interesting these comedians kind of have
this pass a little bit okay well of
course how do you like decide what's too
far yeah as long as you're playing you
get away with everything that's that's
how I feel as long as it's playful if
like if you're standing on it you're
like this is how I feel
then you're gonna get [__] and you've
got to try to defend it like if Andrew
Tate was like I'm joking I don't believe
any of this [__] then nobody would give
a [__] but he's like I don't know what
it means it's funny at the same time it
won't be as funny and he wouldn't be
able to make as much money right so it's
like it's a very tricky thing where he's
got to be like I do believe this but I'm
also being hyperbolic he did a pod with
him we're gonna upload it tomorrow but
he did admit he said some of the [__] he
was joking of course he's joking he's
like a fun like you can look at him and
be like the way you're organizing these
ideas you're like kind of funny and
you're thoughtful and like he's not a
dumb guy he's like a stand-up guy in the
way exactly so it's like but he can't
call himself a comedian he has to say
I'm serious and once you say you're
serious about wild [__] then people go
okay what's wrong with you yeah you know
what I mean so with comedians like look
we like to be playful like human beings
like to be playful and we like to play
with [__] that scares us you know what I
mean like [__] Halloween is just
we're afraid of death and we're like how
do we play with it to get more
comfortable with it I want to get your
take on the Nick Cannon I don't know if
he's having children he had his 12th kid
today yeah his 11th one last week yeah
do we know how many different baby mamas
is it 12 different ones I don't know if
it's 12 different ones but either way
it's a shitload of kids yeah so you
think that's like a flex or is that a
financial decision that is how rich
people Flex now though but that's
because it's expensive
because that is do you think that's a
pull-out problem
I could afford it like that's all we're
thinking right we're going I don't think
you can 12 kids child support's
expensive I think child support cuts off
after like three oh [__] does it yeah I
think there's some weird rules with that
maybe Cali's different but somebody
could look that up someone way smarter
than me but I think it stops at a
certain point but who do you Flex yo I
got 12 kids too it's all over there
we're talking about it yeah
like Bugatti or whatever it's like
people got Bugattis they got nice
watches all that kind of [__] you buy
that once it's done but like them kids
you gotta look after so they're 18. like
that's a super Flex like you guys how
many kids you guys got none broke boys
how many years
we just broke in a restaurant Nick
Cannon got it but do you think that's a
pull out problem or you think no I think
you get addicted to creating life
I want to have kids badly my wife and I
are trying to have kids so what's
holding that up uh come
you can't produce certain eggs you know
what I mean nah bro we just started like
a month or two but yeah who knows I
gotta get my [__] checked out how long
have you guys been married almost a year
how does it change the relationship once
you get married they don't really
yeah do you recommend marriage I guess
you can't really say yeah I do yeah I
actually really do recommend marriage
well you posted uh he's on his nine year
anniversary no you guys married no nine
year anniversary both this girl yeah why
not just do it
um I met your girl she seems sweet
did you do you not want to get married
no she doesn't you don't believe it no
she does
no we we want to so then what's the
holdup
I mean they're young still see what are
you 24 24 yeah but even if you get
married then it doesn't work out that's
okay
you tried it I think it will work out
it's definitely something I want to do
with her so yeah I think just I don't
know
it will happen it will happen okay good
how did you propose to your wife I just
did it at uh at this restaurant that she
loves and uh it was corny and I feel
like it was roommate
yeah I went a little bit harder
afterwards but like on the proposals
just in a restaurant and my boy was next
to me he'd been with his girl for five
years I've been with my girl for like
two or three two years and I had to wait
for him to leave because he was like
[__] if you propose to your wife
in front of my girl who I've been with
for five years she's gonna kill me so I
just let him leave he finished eating at
the restaurant and then I said uh it's
all right bro yeah yeah I just yeah it
was it was cool
yeah marriage is cool man y'all should
get married talked about Mr Beast about
the prenup thing yeah is that like a
thought for you or to get a prenup yeah
yeah for sure it's a dog did you do it
no
well how do you go about that it's a big
gamble yeah but that's marriage I don't
think you're married if you got a prenup
no no no it's about legally doing it no
it's about committing a hundred percent
what about in 10 years would you regret
that if like Scott forbid yeah if God
forbid it went I'd be like yeah this is
[__] up but then that's the risk you
take but if you're going all in with
somebody and the idea is that you guys
have this unit and you're going to build
something together no matter what and
you can't sign some paperwork that is
basically assuming it's going to break
down
very true you know
you guys don't have girls
not at the moment no no I mean you're 38
right 39 39 we're a little bit younger
we're not that young I'm 28 yeah 28. but
you could have a girlfriend you don't
have to you know got Mains but we're
always on the road it's like that NBA
lifestyle yeah so it's a little tough
yeah you can't say loyal well I don't
know yeah
well when they're on the road and you
got chicks I don't know you go to
different cities yeah yeah yeah like
whatever yeah like you tell me you have
an IUD then I'm not again yeah oh really
is that a bad take you think what if if
they got an eye if they say yo I got an
IUD and you just let it fly
um NBA do you yeah you [__] like an
NBA player
yeah I don't know man I I would I would
wear condoms why not just pull out you
like nutting inside if they say IUD you
like that it's say less yeah really yeah
do you get a lot of [__] sometimes
sometimes yeah it depends it depends if
it's a dirty okay it's like a religion
yeah what do you mean well it depends on
it's if I'm really attracted to the girl
then yeah yeah yeah okay if this guy
drinks and he doesn't no I think he's
got good yeah the next day you know like
watch out like don't talk he's gonna be
in the worst mood but it's pretty rare
he's the best he's relaxed he's a big
guy to be around yeah no but you got
good chat I feel like you'd be fun oh
thank you yeah and this is probably good
being part of all this right yeah it
definitely helps yeah it gets you you
know foot in the door and then once you
start talking and then you can do what
you do best did that help you when you
started to take off as a comedian
um did it help me get laid [__] yeah no
I always got laid
being a stand-up comedian sauce though
yeah yeah it's sauce but like I it never
was like
yeah I never did comedy get [__] or
nothing like that like yeah I was happy
that I was able to get laid before
comedy because then I see certain Comics
they do comedy get [__] and it just
bothers me there's guys like that out
there really how can you tell I mean you
just look at the jokes like if every
joke is like men are so dumb oh no way
there's guys riding like that yeah to
appeal to women they're like left-wing
comedians yeah there's everything I
guess there is yeah I don't really
consider those people comedians I don't
know I just don't like I mean yeah
there's I think there's both you know I
think that I personally I don't think
you should be any Wing if you're a real
comedian what Wing are you but like
purposely trying to I would never let
anybody know well you're supposedly
trying to appeal takes away the comedy
right because you can't misdirect if I
know the direction you're going every
single time
then you can and it also like
being so polarized is like it's just the
worst [__] thing you can't get away
with a single joke I was just telling
this to John it's like the second you
establish a side
everything that you say can and we built
will be used against you by the
opposition because they view your
viewpoints as something is trying to
destroy their life
instead of what we all are just like
people trying to make it through life
and anything that make a deal so I would
never take a side right that's something
you guys got to be careful with because
I'm sure the perception of you guys is
right wing yeah but you're all Canadian
so I'm just Canadian they're American
Saleem is Canadian nice Ethiopian oh is
he yeah
well I knew he wasn't not even like he's
not [__] voting oh really yeah he
thought he was Canadian like you nah oh
so it's just you and we have a lot of
Canadians in the squad like back end
front end but okay I like Canadians man
do you yeah you're one of the few really
yeah who doesn't like Canadians yeah why
don't you like them it's kind of
annoying I don't know but like they just
don't get like common sense in America
and like the the greatest country in
America you know what I'm saying oh no
this is the greatest country so yeah I
don't know I just noticed like the
Tendencies it's just like this [__]
Canadian doesn't tell people you're from
Miami when you're from Denver okay well
yeah I'm from Toronto at least like
you're not even from Toronto bro no I
mean me yeah yeah you're from
Mississippi
Long Island he's like saying he's from
the city he's from Long Island this is
Toronto light or whatever yeah he knows
what I'm talking about Canadian [__]
no but yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
everyone wants me from this only from
the six when they [__] when Drake's
from there and [__] it's like Drake
Drake Made Toronto cool man straight up
but I like just Canadians in general I
like how they are nice people kind
people I trust their kindness
isn't that the dope thing about having
some Fame
is that you could be nice to people and
they trust it
do you have people from New York that
hit you up or like want to put New York
on their back in what way like if he's
from Canada and all the Toronto people
you know they have like that connection
yeah you have a connection with New York
people yeah of course yeah like I'm I'm
yeah I am the way I am because of the
people here yeah yeah
and I take responsibility I guess for it
like you want to put New York on the map
type [__] I don't you can't put New York
it's already on the map yeah everyone
wants to claim they're like the King of
New York though yeah so yeah I don't
know if you've said that or not nah man
you don't need to be get that product
placement that's not distracting
um yeah I don't
King of New York
who is the King of New York in your
opinion
it's got to be the ogs if we're being
real
it's an OG type of thing like who's the
King of New York
that's a great question I don't know you
think you're the King of New York no I
didn't say that oh he's just trying to
get included okay
you really you got it like that no I
don't
um who do you think is a king of New
York is
is cardi or Nikki from New York
both party probably cardi B oh really
yeah I mean yeah
too popular musician I don't know I
don't think you could be a king of New
York if you're a musician what do you
have to be a comedian because you're not
claiming that nobody I don't know it's
like uh who is the
the cultural curator of New York
you know yeah I don't know I don't know
right now right now side talk is King
yeah yeah they're big with
them yeah of course but like right now
they're representing New York in a way
yeah yeah and sometimes it takes an
outsider right yeah so it's like
is is cool well I know Jax I think from
around but like sometimes you need
someone from outside to look in and see
what's spectacular and amazing because
the [__] that's right in front of you is
just too obvious to you when they were
really small we had like a call with
them and they were debating like signing
with us yeah and they passed on us no
way but like it worked out like yeah it
worked out for them but it was smart for
you guys to look after it I was watching
them from like when they were small
really but like it wasn't we just had a
call and then they're like yo I think
we're just gonna kind of do our own
thing like love you boys like appreciate
it but and now they're killing it so and
they're still helping us like they show
up to happy Dad yeah it's dope yeah no
they're absolutely questioning they're
representing the culture in the best way
yeah that's the thing like if you put
the culture on the map then you're King
and I think that they're doing that
beautifully right now so that's good you
were trying to sign them
I just yeah we're kind of smart guy huh
I mean I try I try yeah try so are you
the brains behind this [__] no we got a
bunch of brains now yeah but originally
I'm one of them but now we got John we
got Sam Steve's a smarter guy than
people know too now this guy's this
guy's this guy's sharp thinks he's smart
but you shark this guy's sharp yeah
Steve's your one mess up was the getting
kicked off YouTube that's the one thing
because never let them take away your
ability to control your narrative you
still got this you could talk yeah but
that's the one thing like when I saw
that even happen with like Tate and all
the guys it was like you don't want to
die on this because if you can't speak
people forget about you immediately yeah
you know don't let them take away your
ability but your specials on YouTube too
though yeah so how many everything's
YouTube but how many people are telling
you oh this might not fly but Steve's
was definitely weird and you overrule
them and say you don't want to be me oh
hold on what wait what are you I'm just
saying like because your stuff's on
YouTube yeah and you you do a little bit
borderline stuff so of course to be as
close as I possibly can I want to go how
many people are saying yo this might not
work and you're over ruling that and
saying yeah like you're saying at
YouTube the company no but like if
you're gonna talk about like make the
blackface jokes like you do in your
special yeah like how many people are
like yo that might not fly on YouTube
nobody has said anything there that's
the only thing I learned about comedy is
like
if you do a joke to the person you're
talking about and they laugh you can't
be offended it was just a bunch of white
people in the crowd we're talking about
why blackface is okay in this situation
in a situation I think I was like if it
was a Navy SEAL right I was like they
have to do it right which I think is a
funny sketch like the idea of like this
woke Navy SEAL like showing up and he's
gonna do it and even the black guys are
like painted the [__] up he's like guys
I went like to me just the visual that
was funny but but yes like if you're
doing it to black dudes and black chicks
and they're laughing no white lady can
like report you for sure you know what
I'm saying so when you're making the
black face jokes are you looking in the
audience trying to find that guy
laughing absolutely what if there's
nothing else do you say yo zoom in on
the black guy
yeah four different Black Faces I went
through a bunch of different ones yeah
right just black face black face and
then all of a sudden when you're
watching you're like oh I don't feel the
discomfort yeah because they're in on
the job and they're all smiling and
laughing beautiful teeth yeah you guys
got good teeth too are these real no no
you are yours my real teeth I'm gonna
get fake one soon I think really yeah
but you do have the worst teeth at the
table there's no you're fake bro
compared to everybody what about
compared to you I think I have better
teeth than you yeah you do yeah but
yours are real yeah
okay I didn't have it you didn't have
braces I didn't have braces okay and
then what happened I just grabbed my
teeth oh okay I'm gonna get fake ones
and then you'll have the worst ones yeah
what are you so stressed about dude wait
a minute
it's anxiety with this group yeah really
yeah
always filming everything type [__] oh
and you're worried that like it's gonna
be you caught out of context or
something like that yeah he pissed on me
a couple weeks ago that's fire yeah well
this is what held your injury he'll get
really [__] up before a podcast uh-huh
and then I feel like we're going to be a
little more [__]
get him drunk he'll regret everything he
says and then when we see the edit he
tries to cut everything out and remove
that okay that's a little Annoying one
time
well it was with Andrew Tate yeah and
what I learned from that is a shot yeah
that moonshine anytime you [__] test
Andrew Tate the top G fans come out and
or after your [__] yeah right but
y'all got fans that ride for you too
right yeah yeah but his fans are Next
Level bro really yeah oh yeah yeah
people are just commenting about you
just because that's your character bro
when people how many people ask you for
photos today just the Moonshine that's
bad yeah no it's good we can do it yeah
yeah I'm gonna put this [__] don't put
your fingers in the car I'm not gonna
finger blast your cup bro
you don't wait you don't believe in
finger blasting
steiny why don't you go by Steinberg
uh because they they came up with
starting signing yeah
well I still rap Steinberg don't worry
you do okay good how do you feel about
Kanye
not a fan not a fan no I think uh
I appreciate you saying something too I
appreciate you saying something oh are
you Jewish yeah yeah I feel like a lot
of people [__] got scared there they
did get a little scared yeah [__]
[__] so I appreciate you what so what
was your reaction to it what did he say
by the way uh he just this guy he said
Defcon isn't it great I mean it's pretty
big yeah this is what being rich is no
no no no it's a big deal no no this is
what be I've thought a lot about this
being rich without kids is this how
meaning like the world doesn't matter to
you no but all I just saw was that he's
anti-semitic exactly I don't know but I
never saw they never said exactly what
he said they just sent Annie semester
he's going to play the majority against
us
saw the headline right and then you said
no I don't give a [__] right and then
research exactly yeah because you don't
have to because nothing that happened
matters right like you have money in the
bank and if all this goes to [__] you
could just go I'll go to Barbara you
researched it no oh you know of course
no I looked it into it and obviously I
was you know I thought that what he was
saying was kind of silly but I also
think Connie is just kind of corny in
general yeah brilliant producer of music
but like as a guy he's just kind of the
only thing I'll say is Connie's an idiot
I don't really care Kyrie Irving a
little more upset with but also that guy
preached that the world was flat for
five or six years to everybody so his
opinion to me how do you know it's not
flat I mean there's photos and everybody
in the world knows that it's not yeah
this is a fun way to go down though yeah
hey how do you know how do you know hey
photos [__] every scientist every app
where'd you learn that the Jewish media
yeah did you learn that from the Jewish
media yeah JCC Ranch Camp yeah okay good
that's they want you to think that it's
wrong you don't think it's around it's
flat is it like they want you you went
to the next game the next day unplugged
from The Matrix bro
leave the Matrix what's the most you
would spend on fake teeth
um um I don't know how much they cost
how much you spend oh
it was expensive yeah yeah you don't
care about money and [__] huh what do
you know about people that people don't
know that's why I think your Brilliance
is what like what do you understand
about people
um
I I don't think I understand anything
about people nah
nah in what context I think that you
have a you have a great understanding of
like The Human Condition and how people
react to things and I think it's very
simple to you in your head and I think
that's why you're able to curate and
create content that leads into these
things
well I unders I that's actually probably
Steve's best yeah quality
I know that humans are able to like pick
up on like authenticity and like it's
like one of our I know that's a thing
and I think I resonate with people in a
good way 100 and um I kind of don't care
about a lot of things yeah like and
making my YouTube videos I've had to
like borrow money from my parents like
multiple times really still no not still
below no no not in the beginning and
like when I was spending millions of
dollars like no when I come up the money
you gave them
money I gave them yeah yeah yeah yeah
run it back Mom and Dad yeah yeah I mean
I think that's the reason why I was so
successful successful is going just all
in both the wall not giving a [__] and
having fun with it yeah I do have fun I
think you said that he shouldn't have
got his YouTube deleted what do you
think he could have done
I mean did you know about the gambling
thing we had spoken about this a little
bit when it first happened I thought it
was really [__] up well I knew about
it and it was on my second channel right
so we're like we did we were blurring
the.com and just some of them weren't
fully blurred it was just like a mistake
on my editor but it's just crazy because
in my second Channel getting 100K views
per video yeah and they just took and
they took away everything my name that
should be a strike because I think
there's no questions
dude you're the Brittany grinder of
YouTube bro
like when you really think about it
thank you so much
yeah you are the Brittany grinder of
YouTube thank you so much they got you
out like a [__] Gulag Rumble is just
it's just jail
yeah
it's doing good ripping turnips out of
the ground and [__] or whatever poor
Brittany's doing yeah poor Brittany yeah
I went to Russia actually I know yeah
you were Danny that was crazy yeah it
was insane but yeah you understand
something and you understand how to get
people to react on like a very visceral
Primal way and I think that people spend
millions and millions of dollars trying
to figure that out and hire people to do
it and I don't I don't think that they
do it probably as good as you but you're
right about authenticity it's like moth
to a flame right when everybody's phony
when one person is real we're attracted
to it like politics are the most phony
[__] thing in the world yeah and then
Trump comes around he starts making fun
of all these guys and exposes how funny
they are and whether you like them or
not you're like holy [__] I can't not
watch that yeah for entertainment value
you think he's gonna run again I wanna
well you guys probably know
I feel like he's probably already
announced probably maybe right if by the
time this is up I mean announce it I
heard he's gonna announce announce it
bro well you talk a lot about him in
your special bro yeah he's been saying
like on the 15th people are going to be
very happy yeah or some [__] how do you
feel about him so controversial I think
that he's a perfect example of like how
uh how powerful humor is yeah it's hard
to hate someone that makes you laugh for
sure that's true how I feel about Trump
that's why I liked uh the Trump segment
in your yes Trump is the borderline he
can move it right and it's like he's a
funny he's a genuinely funny like that's
the thing I don't like I think both
sides do this but like when you make
this like overstatement about a person
because you hate them right it's like
people [__] maybe hate Trump so that
he's not funny at all and it's like why
don't we just acknowledge that he's
funny
what do you think's the greatest thing
that he's done humor was oh the uh uh I
mean there's he got a lot of bars bro
but like but number one that means the
one that cracks me up to this day is
when Megyn Kelly I think was like you
called women uh pigs and yeah whatever
he goes just Rose
you know I played this I played like
nine holes with them golfing no he's a
sad funny or what bro he's just like
he's funnier than you'd like really but
like so he did this one thing so after
after we played golf yeah we were like
all eating hot dogs just like on the
picnic bench yeah just like a regular
round and then his assistant comes up to
him and Taps him he's like Mr Trump like
you have a you have an interview to do
in like 15 minutes yeah and then he's
like who's it with and he's like she the
assistant said like Rachel or something
then he looks at us he's like first
question fellas is she pretty he asked
his assistant and the guy's like yeah I
mean she's pretty cute he's like I'm in
it was it was I [__] cried so he
knows how to chop it up he's uh what are
you doing seriously yeah I think if she
wasn't attractive but he would have been
like let's go let's go to number ten
yeah yeah like he went to do the
interview yeah but it was fun why do you
think why do you think Biden and like
his team can't get him good at Twitter
well I think I don't know the Biden
thing to me is all right this is the
thing I think a lot of people won't
admit but they do feel
they like the state of things with Biden
Biden's a corpse right like the guy
can't say like numbers more than five
digits like that's my favorite thing
politically is Biden saying big numbers
yeah
like that is awesome like if it's like
if it's like you know the speech is
coming up and it's like it's just 200
million and like you're like all right
let me go and it just dude 200 million
billion or whatever the [__] he does and
have these beaches so
but I think that the chaos that Trump
induced
was too much for people and I think they
got tired of it now
we all know Biden's pretty much not
alive
and that's embarrassing as Americans but
I think that we like if we're being
honest in our core we like the
Tranquility of Biden sure and I think
that's probably what happened in the
elections like everybody thought this
big red wave was common and [__] like
that like I don't know that much about
[__] politics because I just don't
care about it I think it's stupid
nothing changes yeah the red way of the
Red Wave but nothing happened there's no
red wave
so why is that I mean the guy can't
speak yeah literally the president can't
speak I know it's crazy it's like this
guy isn't even alive yeah but because
life is good we're like all right that's
really what it takes I mean what his
most viral clip is what him falling off
the bike probably right
the Moonshine yeah it's bad no it's good
yeah did you try it yeah yeah did you
try it no but take the whole thing this
is making me not want to try it
that's like a tequila are you guys
selling it are you guys selling this no
no not at all there's no way you're
selling your soul to the night yeah
how much are you guys making off of this
we're doing pretty good is this like
hundreds of millions where's your AP at
I think I mean I think you know what
this is I don't know what I could say he
might
do you like prices
oh that's let me see
pause
I don't know what this is you
usually rocket AP I see I have an AP
Steve you bought Selena 200k watch no no
I don't know what it is this is a
vastron Constantine it's nice super rare
there's probably like five of these in
North America maybe how much you pay for
that I got this one at I think retail so
it's probably like 70 000 or something
like that
so it's like a subtle Flex like you got
to be a watch guy to know yeah I kind of
like the fact that nobody knows what it
is and then I feel now I won't wear it
again because I've just said what it
costs but like you know like people uh
you walk down the street and
everything's you spoil your wife too or
yeah she gets whatever
what's the biggest thing you bought her
her probably her engagement ring will
that run you you say the price a lot
I'm not gonna say it because then little
ballpark or no I'm not gonna say because
I've never told her and I've just been
kind of like making her think it's even
more than it is she's probably asking
like her friends yeah you think it was
100K or I make them lie I'm even the
Jeweler I'm like don't you never know
too right you never know
until divorce and they're like this is
cubics that's yeah that's why yeah
um did you buy Powerball tickets or no
no I [__] up I should have what was it
two billion two billion what would you
do with the two billion that's a good
question right [__] off that's just how
much do you need to [__] off
you've thought about this a lot
like legit [__] off I was like not like
a not like a act like an actual [__] off
yeah yeah
that's like I'm [__] off that was my
problem right now you know 100 neither
would I yeah 50 mil is that's enough
though but that's like that's a low [__]
off number two yeah like I could have
said 100. it's 50 mil now and five years
it will be a hundred mil
and then it probably just what about you
it was 50. yeah and now it's probably a
hundred but then again my motivation
goes down the more money I get like I
want to be happy I want to enjoy things
so honestly yeah yeah
I know I used to want to say like I want
to be a billionaire but now it's like it
depends like it's a I feel like it's all
about the timing in life too you know
can you not work like no I don't know I
I wouldn't know until I got there right
do you know what I mean like I feel like
I feel like maybe if you got there it
all depends I don't know I think with
this game too sometimes it's like it
gets mentally tough sometimes yeah so
sometimes I'm like [__] this but then 95
of the time I'm like I like this it's
fun yeah you know what I mean sometimes
the five percent's like
[__] like maybe if I just had this I
would just chill yeah you know what I
mean 100 can you not work though yeah
how
uh yeah just stopped working but I mean
but if you have to do shows sell out
shows to YouTube to make money oh oh
like do I have enough money to not work
again no I mean like how do you get to
that point where you're like yo [__] off
oh oh yeah I mean now I could [__] off
it would just be a different lifestyle
what kind of Lifestyle are we looking at
Amnesia or some [__] I could be in
America and not care and not it would
just be different than I do now but I'm
also like not I don't know anything
about money I'm like financially
illiterate I know how to make money I'm
really good at making money but I don't
know how to like invest it or do any of
those things like so yeah like I'm just
learning that [__] now it's pathetic
yeah but like yeah I mean this whole
time I should have been like investing
all the money I had I was just letting
it pile up
and it's just a stupid way to go about
it but yeah that's I think that's the
goal it's like I want to experience in
life
what it's like to
let's use the Matrix example like what
it's like to unplug
right right do you use the Matrix just
because of Tate no but I think the
funniest thing about it is like it it
was made by two like trans chicks really
yeah the watoski sisters yeah it's an
allegory for me what the Matrix the
movie isn't that an old movie yeah it
made three of them they just made four
are you big Matrix fan yeah it was the
best movie ever when it came out there
was trans chicks like back then no they
became trans now ah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's um there's a girl in Miami
Nikita Dragon do you know her or not
have you seen that say what Nikita
Dragon yeah did you guys see that she's
being held in the mail but she's in the
men's section and she asked the judge to
be transferred to the women's yeah and
they said no yeah I think that's some
law there yeah yeah I mean they tell you
like you've been to jail yeah I've been
to jail have you been to jail they tell
you to good yeah they tell you to like
you have to get naked yeah oh wow so we
saw that day because you they gotta
check if you have any you strip down and
you put on jail yeah
they probably saw Nikita porn and
they're like I mean well how do you know
she has a horn though
but she might not be finished otherwise
she would have gone to the female jail
yeah yeah well it was evident enough
whatever she had that she was clearly a
male I mean
what do you want man what like in life
uh
I just wanna uh yeah what do you want I
just want to make a lot of enough money
to where I don't care to wear my next
Rumble video on blackface you know and
it's just like to where I just don't
care you know I'm Instagram live
blackface yeah you know [__] like that
yeah and just not care and just be like
true dark humor what would you do when
you when you don't care I wonder about
that for myself
I would just do the the most darkish so
you would continue making the things
you're making yeah except just you know
time to go to work put on my black face
yeah yeah you know like Navy Seals yeah
but I'm filming a video yeah you know
yeah so just take it like I really enjoy
dark humor yeah and I would like to uh
take it to the next level yeah you know
so continue to go more extreme yeah and
with the Financial Freedom just do it
because canceling me and worrying about
all right how am I gonna retire one day
because I got canceled yeah I want to
just have the retirement money yeah you
know and then you get to create freely
yeah yeah that would be that's the goal
right the goal is to create freely yeah
but we have to earn that right we have
to earn that right and I think that's
the thing that a lot of times like we
[__] up when we [__] about you know the
restrictions we go through
is we forget that you got to pay the
price to create freely yeah like we're
not all [__] trust fund kids here
that are just like yeah do whatever you
want we have to earn the money and then
once we make all that money then we get
to choose if we're going to make the
video it's going to get us canceled or
get us thrown off all the other things
yeah but yeah I think that that's smart
your boys would like Joe right yeah I
love Joe yeah does he have that
mentality where it's like I feel like
that's why he's so [__] it's dope
what he can do is just like he's
intensely passionate do you think he
just gives like he doesn't give a [__]
now no he gives so much of a [__] about
specific things yeah and it's like
almost everything I like about like he's
he's got his bag now it's like he's just
true to himself type [__] like whatever
he wants to do he does I think Joe's
always been true to himself and he's
obviously went through like struggles
because of that you know the Carlos
Mencia thing the way we look at it is
like he called out and see if we're
stealing jokes I don't know if you guys
are familiar with that this is earlier
on and
um you know comedy lore but like he also
got a lot of heat for that early on I
think he was banned from The Comedy
Store and did all these other things so
like but yeah Joe's like an intensely
passionate [__] guy and like whatever
he likes or appreciates he goes like all
in 100 on and I think when you're all in
100 it's very easy to defend your
position
right you know what I'm saying because
you're all in and you know everything
about it yeah you know like it makes
sense I would imagine you I don't know
like you've been
I I'm assuming you're involved in the
business side of this a lot
yeah yeah
and
you're hearing about deals and hearing
people complain about deals but you've
also offered people deals yeah right so
you understand both sides right you
understand how to make a deal where
people can be happy
and how to make a deal where somebody's
maybe taken advantage of 100 so like
when you hear Kanye complaining about
the deals you get to look at it as
someone who offers deals
most people don't offer deals true so
they're going well I'm getting [__]
he's probably getting [__] you know
what I'm saying 100 it's hard to have
empathy for that yeah no that makes
sense
I think we lost them
not my fault
I don't even know where I was gonna go
where are we at I have no idea
um I'm pretty buzzed Loki that Moon that
moonshine hit me it's a fan question I
don't know if you want to answer it but
sure what's the weirdest genre of Forney
watch the weirdest John I don't really
watch porn no why is that
well he just got engaged too it's like a
thing not that really do you try and
limit your [__] now that you know your
wife's gonna watch no but I just I'm not
like a big jerk off I mean you have to
admit if the wife's watching now like
you're freshly engaged you got to be a
bit careful though no I don't really
watch a lot of porn to be honest with
you no or were you saying with the [__]
you say you mean yeah yeah oh oh like
about like my wife or these types of
things sure
now
no not really I mean she gets it she you
know she married a comedians okay what
the deal was have you ever made a joke
where you thought it was gonna go really
well and it went really bad
yeah can you give us can you give us an
example of that uh I mean yeah I had a
lot of early in my career like I didn't
know how to get away with jokes so you
don't know that you don't have the
skills to execute them so you just say
these offensive things and then people
get offended give us an example I had
people throw [__] candles at me no
what did you say I don't even remember I
honestly don't remember I can't remember
the violence do you have a favor in like
a comedy club fights all the time
all the time do you have a favorite
group or something you like to go after
or joke about no it's like whatever I'm
passionate about I gotta have like a
interest in it I don't know how to just
make jokes about like uber
like somebody has to bother me I think
that's the hardest thing about having
money is that less things bother you
you know what bothers you the most right
now nothing nothing bothers you you look
at your phone
and everybody's seeming disinterested
were you looking at notes or or texting
girls notes yeah what do you mean me
taking time out of my day to do this and
then feeling dude I'm never forcing you
guys to do the podcast I've never been
more excited to do a podcast say again
I've never been more excited I'm sorry I
don't apologize no apologize you asked
me what annoyed me and I gave you an
honest answer where are you being
serious about that yeah that annoyed me
really yes so if someone is that
surprising to you well if I'm looking at
my notes I have some things personally
that I wrote that I wanted to ask you
not okay okay so I can't look at that
and then ask you that I mean you can I
guess what if someone in the audience is
on their phone when you're doing that
and they don't get the same treatment
you got would you call them out yes have
you done that before
yes and how's that reaction
good they get as offensive as I do I
don't think you're offensive I think
you're offended offended yeah yeah
yeah
all right well my fault there's no fault
it's fine you asked me how I felt I gave
you an honest reaction all right my bad
[__] did you uh do you see the Andrew
Paul uh Andrew J Jake Paul [__] I
thought it was cool
that shit's crazy bro yeah do you think
it'll actually go down
do you think Tate's uh is uh seriously
Muslim
what he converted to Islam he said right
yeah why'd you put quotes on it well I
mean he just randomly said he converted
to Islam well you can quote you can
become Muslim many times
he's Christian and Romanian and Muslim
when he's in Dubai so you think he might
be Faking It
I mean I I think I don't know what that
means I'm not a religious guy but if
you're Christian in Romania and then
Muslim in Dubai I don't really know what
that means but what do you think what do
you think
I mean I I believe him that he's Muslim
in Dubai like I know he doesn't he
wasn't drinking yeah anywhere with them
definitely when I when we talk to him I
noticed that he's a lot more chill now
and I think I don't know if he'll admit
it but I definitely think the whole
cancel thing I mean that pressure of
that [__] even for like anybody bro
that's insane like yeah the entire world
coming at you like that like intense
that's gotta change you a bit yeah I
think so I think when I when we like
talk to him last I noticed he was a lot
different like did you watch our new pod
with him it's like
it's like a hundred to zero compared to
our our first one really it's like I
don't know it's just more like
interesting would you ever have them on
YouTube speaker I was talking to him
well why would he
um
he wants to do [__] in person he told me
yeah like so he was in Romania and we
were in London and I was like come to
London and he was like man I don't know
if I can and then I was like ah it might
be tough to come to Romania like I know
you guys went to Croatia we went to
Croatia yeah yeah we just kind of jumped
on it because he was so big at the time
yeah like we loved him we thought he was
[__] hilarious and we just is it
possible to ride out Fame when you're
when you get famous that fast
that's something I think see yeah
everyone different people say that to me
like yo Tate's not going to be around
Tate's not going to be around yeah
people said that to me like two months
ago yeah and I was like I don't know
there's kind of something about this guy
smart enough that's very unique and like
to me he's funny and the [__] he said
about girls I found was clearly a joke
and it was funny some gets [__] up
whatever but
I think just his his outlook on the
world and he's definitely smart and he's
an amazing speaker yeah so until he
decides that he's gonna quit I feel like
he's gonna be around but as long as he
might be the exception as long as he
wants to do it I think that he's gonna
find a way because he's a very good
speaker yeah he's about like a range of
[__] that's right he's very thoughtful
yeah it's very thoughtful yeah I'm
curious to see like how his his Arc
plays out and that Jake fight is
interesting I like the fact that Jake is
fighting fight the biggest fights you
know every time I talk to Jake I'm just
like please do not let these
[__] make you fight a boxer
like why did he fight that when I saw
him that haseem [__]
what the boxer that's when you know the
comments get to him yeah and we all do
that like we're all human at the end of
the day like people say [__] you want to
prove them wrong I'm glad he didn't do
that yeah it's like yo make the money
and get out with some brain cells like
get fighting fighting a boxer if it's
Canelo and then Canelo beats you and you
make 100 million dollars and then you
just retire okay fine but I don't think
don't fight some random just for the
[__] just to please people yeah or
just to prove your hater because your
haters always going to find something to
discredit you so even if you do beat the
boxer it's gonna be like well he wasn't
a professional or something like
yeah now Jake is Jake is doing it right
now man
crazy yeah before we finish who would
you guys think would win that fight
between Tate and Jake yeah I think
boxing I feel like Jake Paul would be
the heavy favorite I think after that
last fight I think he would man and also
like I I think who do you think makes
more sense I haven't seen tape really
fight that I think tape brings in more
of a pay-per-view the tricky thing is
like you want they both do they both do
I mean yeah you want Jake to be a Healer
I hate selling more tickets the best
fight for Jake is when he's fighting
someone that people love
because Jake is like a Mayweather thing
where like people paid to see Mayweather
lose true right yeah so it's like Jake
should fight Tom Hanks like who's the
most beloved person like that you know
you should want to see that hero of
yours finally beat Jake so the question
about the Tate fight is
but a lot of people consider Tate their
hero they do but I don't know if there's
enough people that
you just like
Anderson Silva wasn't just a fighter he
was all of MMA do you know what I mean
yeah so it's like he's I think it'd be
way bigger than that fight though yeah
yeah
I'm curious
shit's at like a mill likes and 11.
12.5 mil views on Jake Paul on Jake
Paul's page yes it's it's gonna be huge
12. in 11 hours yeah that is insane are
you a big UFC fan yeah I really like you
I saw you had Bruce Buffer introduce you
yeah how dope was that how much did that
cost you how do you do it for free no no
no we put some money in his pocket but
he's very sweet I I just didn't want to
inconvenience him and we got to fly him
out did you get when that guy [__]
announced dude he's just the man like
and
the energy is there like he didn't
half-ass anything like he's just that
dude have you met Izzy
no but what do you think of his Vibe bro
he's the best I saw him make a comment
at a press conference where he was like
yo I'm gonna do a tick tock dance once I
beat you yeah and that really just like
maybe not anymore
I know but I'm not like a date I'm not a
[__] UFC Warrior bro like I'm not in
the ring funny and somebody is what is
this tick tocks with Gabe yeah yeah yeah
why are you on Tick Tock I'm trying to
understand like is this your character
are you like the hater or something like
what's who am I hating on I'm just like
I'm trying to understand like you're
you're hating on Izzy for doing Tick
Tock dances when you do Tick Tock dance
oh like I love I love Justin
poirier's your last tick tock yeah yeah
can you explain what what the dynamic is
here like you guys are like friends with
these people you're the newest so you
could take the shots like I'm trying to
understand what it is like you're gonna
have to see him
that's funny yeah
he's got a sense of humor he's a
comedian that's funny he's from the
recipe but that's like Tick Tock but
he's making fun of tick tocks yeah yeah
see he's got a real comedian here yeah
real comedian no yeah yeah we're not
there yet yeah yeah yeah we're there
we're there yeah I like what you're
doing no but he's like he's like a tech
talker this guy like he he goes for it
bro this was a trend yeah
but they hate you know you can't hate
them no don't don't hate on tick though
no you're trying to get [__] that's
what it is remember I told you the
comics trying to get [__] oh you think
I'm that guy what gives you that read
everyone is a girl trend
yeah so what no there's nothing wrong
with it you should maximize it bro
you're short no no I'm not saying it's
bad I'm like you have to maximize your
Fame in order to get the highest what is
it value female or whatever it is yeah
you think so a hundred percent I think
you should got it but I think I think
you're a smart guy he's a funny guy
though I think yeah like I think that
like if girls gave you the chance they'd
go I actually really kind of like this
guy a lot okay what gives you that read
if you just met me though because you're
you're smart you know what you're doing
yeah I don't know
but yeah you got to make a name for
yourself you got to find like a way to
how often do you watch our stuff because
I feel like you're pretty educated
the guy I think you're the guy that acts
like he doesn't know anything about it
but I've never watched a podcast of in
its entirety but you know Steve's on
Rumble you've watched a lot of the now
Steve is a part of culture okay so
things that Steve do and that's what I
think is most impressive is that you
found a way to like
yeah I mean you just you get it bro you
found a way to be part of culture
um and then when I come on a podcast I
try to be prepared you know so like I
did a little research on all you guys
how do you prepare like what do you
watch I watch at least
at least clips of a podcast like I was
watching parts of the the Elon stuff I
was watching parts of the the yachty
stuff the yachty was interview was
hilarious because you guys were like
interviewing Drake through yachty
that I mean it was just so what's it
like hanging with Drake yeah I mean I
don't I don't that wasn't me but yeah
that's what you're saying yeah yeah but
he was great his energy to to handle
that
um
but yeah
yeah I don't know I like I like to be
researched when I go on and talk to
people it makes me feel more confident
I want to know what I'm going to expect
what do you think of recently Elon with
that eight dollar verification are you
on Twitter I am on Twitter are you gonna
pay the eight dollars
you seem like a eight Dollar pay guy why
what makes you feel that way you want to
have that like verification sauce
you think why do you think that I just
want to get that Vibe because it's like
if you're not verified on Twitter but
you're on all platforms you want to have
that like sauce yeah I could see why
well do you agree or no
um no I I don't really care about the
verification
it's good I miss something
are you guys friends with each other
yeah like yeah you don't get that Vibe
no why not because the chemistry is
weird
well I there's almost none of it why do
you say that I don't know it's just I
like
I don't get it what's what's confusing
it's just that so I can help break it
down for you it's like a weird thing
this is the first time we've done a
podcast I don't do podcasts no no you
you all right you're an interesting one
I think Thailand no but you're just an
interesting you're but like do you guys
like do you have stories where you like
bust balls like they're yeah well we
usually have a different guy who sits in
yeah we wanted to have Steve on this one
so yeah Brad yeah yeah yeah I love Brad
too yeah he's great and what Brad
usually drives it or something like that
what do you mean like is he usually
driving the interview why you don't
think we're doing a good job of that no
not really I mean it's not my favorite
this is a joke I don't understand yeah
right I gotta I don't know like do you
guys are you guys having a good time I I
was until is this what it's normally
like no I mean I was having a good time
okay I never do them and when I do them
I stay silent but with you he did the
Trump one I did see clips of the the
Trump one I didn't say a word that's not
true you gave him a watch yeah but
were you nervous what was the what was
the feeling nervous but also I really
like I really like Trump I just I'm not
good at speaking so like even here I'm
just not good at speaking why do you say
that he's got a very endearing quality
so I just kind of stay silent yeah
well why didn't why didn't you speak on
the Trump podcast I just I couldn't get
myself to I mean I was I see why people
are so drawn to you you have a very
endearing quality but you also say the
most [__] up crazy things yeah so
people are probably really protective of
you I would imagine
I don't know like were people Furious
when you got canceled oh yeah for sure
yeah yeah a lot of people were yeah
because they're like he's a nice guy
and he does funny [__] up [__] yeah
but you're getting rid of a guy who's
genuinely nice yeah yeah a lot of people
are mad but I think everything's going
good right now like I'm making videos
getting a million views per video which
I'm happy with I mean yeah a new
platform which is great which has a
fraction of the people so to get those
numbers it's unreal yeah so I always
have like almost have like the same
amount of people watching live like I
had like 25 000 people watching them
Rumble like while my videos going live
and on YouTube it's just like 30 and
they'll never let you back on YouTube no
but I also text YouTube [__] [__]
up [__] I get drunk and then I text it
oh you just raise text them who do you
text yeah I don't know her name but I
have her on a contact as YouTube I'm
just like is that the girl that called
yeah I just fire off on her sometimes
does it say delivered uh no she she's
actually a Brokey she has uh the green
uh yeah but
um
yeah
and you know what I'm talking about you
got to take the number to WhatsApp to
see if it delivers yeah I have her on I
can message her on what's up she does
what she tells you
oh nice yeah yeah but yeah I have a
loyal fan base a little fan base yeah
yeah that's good you guys are good at
curating that you speak to them
personally I noticed that at the
beginning of the videos
what's up guys what's up what's up boys
yeah yeah you watched it have you seen
any of us I watched the beginning of the
video that I see you doing what's up
boys how you doing
is that now do you think that that's
manipulative what's up boys yeah I don't
think so I don't know we just kind of do
it yeah oh there's no thinking behind it
at all really no yeah you're not like if
I can Galvanize this audience and like
curate this fan base and not really
they'll buy all my [__] I mean honestly
not at all I think we're just so yeah
we're talking about what you don't do
that too huh you don't do that at all
yeah but for that reason no but we do it
too because we have loyal film base
though yeah so what you're saying you do
do you do it well I mean no we just say
what's up to the boys they watch every
episode you're saying you do or you
don't you're saying both things we don't
think like that I don't think I've just
personally done so many of those that
it's like I don't know I just feel like
I think it's I think brilliant I think
it's brilliant you will have millions of
people and you're finding a way to make
each one of them personally feel
connected to you and I think that the
people who do that well have the most
success especially when it come comes to
like
good like this is so [__] genius
[Music]
hey cam [__] was just a saying I
guess not
honey I'm home quick
[Music]
hey babe
hi honey
uh how's work it was good
why are you still in bed
I'm just reading
with a happy Dad
I mean
it's Friday right
yeah you're right thank God honestly
we still doing dinner later uh-huh
okay good I'm starving
babe where'd you get this palette of
happy Dad
these aren't even bad 100 calories 2
grams of carbs
it's almost like cheating
[Music]
I could see why you like these
this is like when I saw the number like
people would tell me what you guys were
doing with the merch and I was like holy
[__] like they have a movement and then
when I saw this
I was like when you're going to product
because products is not [__] easy no
it's not like
this to me was the most impressive thing
I've seen you guys do the videos which
are hilarious turning this into an
actual [__] thing
that's next level appreciate it alcohol
game is not easy for sure it's a mafia
yeah it's a [__] political it is a
[__] it's so political bro bro when
you hit me up yesterday you're like I'm
going to meet liquor companies yeah you
gotta kind of Kiss the Ring a little bit
you have to bro you can't even yeah
shake hands [__] kiss babies and [__]
you could have millions of people who
you know ride for you yeah and it
doesn't matter unless you go go makes
you understand how the world ticks yeah
sure like yeah so how do you continue to
satisfy your fans and and what they want
the content they want while also
satisfying that's what that's what we're
dealing with and it's a struggle every
day and we got to make certain decisions
yeah yeah yeah because that's because
you got to stay true to yourself too
like don't want to sell out but that's
the thing that the BR that the companies
always do they they love that you're
wild they love that you're hilarious
until they oh yeah and then it's like oh
don't do this yeah it's like I'm wild
and hilarious that's why people are
going to buy or drink exactly that's why
people feel like a connectivity
they see the videos and they go oh
that's me and my friends
have you ever dealt with something like
that yeah
for sure was the point where you had to
like
I mean obviously with the special it was
big but they're like certain brands even
with the podcast who are like
to be honest it's been pretty good
that's the beauty of numbers also like
when you deliver that's the thing I
realized about Hollywood
and most of these uh companies is like
everybody's in a race to be second
you know what I mean by that
how so like uh right now there's no
rated R comedies
I'm gonna make a rated R comedy and it's
gonna [__] make a quarter million
dollars for the buck or quarter billion
dollars at the box office and after that
every studio is gonna go
it's time to make rated R comedies it's
okay let the floodgates out we could
actually do it now right now everybody's
terrified because they're where they're
going to lose their job it takes one and
usually an independent Force to do it
and then everybody wants to jump on
board
so it's like
I imagine some of these companies were
terrified when you're putting out
podcasts and then they saw them [__]
numbers and they saw people walk into
Costco or wherever you can what's the
the biggest retailer that you guys have
these at probably like Ralph's Ralph
sort of walking around they [__] sell
out and all of a sudden it's like oh
yeah let them do the tape episode let
them do
I know
it's a [__] weird time right now yeah
but it's numbers don't lie man I know
as long as you don't get too locked I
think it's politics I think it's
Financial system if you become political
or you question the financial system the
powers that be
that's facts that's what happened to
Portland Oregon 's doing all that
[__] gamble not even gambling up what
was it uh
he was doing the day trader or something
like that yeah Davey day trader and all
of a sudden it was he stopped well I
don't know if he stopped but I know that
they tried to make that [__]
radioactive and there were articles
coming out in the Business Insider about
me too [__] like you've never heard
anything before that he goes and [__]
with the stock market and then literally
Business Insider why would Business
Insider be publishing articles I don't
you don't think there's a coincidence
there that [__] scares me bro that's
what I'm that's and that's why you gotta
think about that with politics it's like
if you guys were like no because uh left
wing or right wing it they just they
want to devour you with Rogue gonna
happen every single time that he's
supported a candidate the next day
there's an article about the worst thing
that he possibly said I gave Trump uh
presidential election so I feel like
that could have something to do can we
make a cancellation I don't know really
I don't know I mean like they just
cancel me out of nowhere like it was
yeah it seemed like they have Vendetta
I'm gonna be honest with you like I
didn't think that was really fast but
with like what I was doing it was like
it wasn't like
right to just delete my entire YouTube I
don't know why you can't just make
another page and then at least abide by
the very strict rules that they would
give you but the things I was abiding by
the rules on Steve will do it
strikes on Steve will do it Steve will
do it too you know it's frustrating also
I can imagine being in your shoes where
it's like
you know that you are made an example of
and then people
people aren't acknowledging well it was
unfair yeah at least at least let
YouTube be like yeah we crucified you on
purpose then you could go to bed but it
wasn't fair just because like the
website that they canceled me for is
allowed on their platform yeah so that's
why it's really unfair you're allowed to
say hey I'm on stake yeah I'm doing this
on stage yes website but God forbid you
show the.com and then it's over it's
over yeah there's only a few like
gambling sites I feel bad I feel like
you came at me a little bit there why do
you feel bad I just feel like you
targeted me is you or no no I thought
you were just being a little Annoying
how
I think that I think you're annoying
really a little bit yeah yeah yeah yeah
and what made me what makes you think
that I don't know I was just gonna be
like a therapy session yeah I mean what
the [__] are you like I don't know if
you're playing a character or you're
having like an insecure moment if you're
having a vulnerable insecure moment then
I want to like talk about kind of
playing something but what oh say that
trigger wouldn't say that I think he's
so insecure and
I think he plays his character he's so
insecure what did I say that triggered
you do you find it hard to be yourself I
think that's that's what I do bro
do you think but I get [__] on a lot for
doing that no you get [__] on me because
of the character you play because you
can't be yourself it's hard to be around
people who are being themselves what did
I do that piss you off I wouldn't say I
was pissed off why would you say would I
do that annoyed you you were the one
that came back and said that you felt
hurt I do feel hurt because I feel like
you got pissed off at me well that's
what happens when you have real
reactions when you're being phony
with somebody it doesn't get any
reaction you can't be upset when was
iPhone even but you're doing exactly
what you should do you should try to get
your moments this is a good moment for
you bro you're crazy you think I'm doing
this for clicks even the way your voice
sounds when you say it isn't real
right now but like you're coming at me
so I'm curious he thinks I'm Jewish you
are aren't you no oh yeah
you would do this to your Jewish brother
huh no never wow that we roll like that
wow that's [__] up no just say how you
honestly feel don't I feel good bro I
think you're pretty you don't feel good
you don't feel good you feel insecure
right now because you think I don't like
you I I do I think why do you think I
don't like you because you turned on me
like probably like an hour 20 into the
Pod and was there anything that maybe
you did to change my energy towards you
or do or how about this do you think
that I gave you a fair shot in the
beginning you did but I I sent a text
during the Pod and I think that's when
it turned right when it turned
maybe I don't know your line of
questioning after that wasn't great
but I do I do sense that you're playing
a bit of a character and I don't have as
much of a tolerance for characters as I
do for authenticity you don't think I'm
being authentic I think in certain
moments you were in that kind of like
irritates me and what can you give us
especially if it's antagonistic if
you're playing a character because
you're insecure and you're just trying
to do your best to like exist in this
moment which is a high stakes moment
that's okay but can you give me an
example of when you felt that I think I
think you need attention I think you're
doing anything you can to get attention
and right now you're making this podcast
about you which is the most boring part
of the conversation we have much more
interesting people to discuss whose
lives are more fascinating no oh [__] I
don't have to do a podcast again
straight up even that doesn't sound real
you might have just retired him oh
straight up to this [__] again no you'd
never walk away from that
I I honestly can't tell if you're
playing a character or not and I think
that that's a real problem
right now you don't you just have to
decide if you do the fact that you're
upset makes me feel like you don't think
I am
got it well thank you so much for
hurting my self-esteem and probably
keeping me inside tonight
hope you have a great night even that's
not real it's so real you're going out
tonight yeah you're gonna party it's
okay man oh my God you're new to this
right
how how long you've been doing this
entertainment
a while I think you're a smartphone
don't get Charles gold bro no I want to
get him going you're going to get it I
do think you're a smart guy okay I do
think you're a smart dude I I genuinely
mean that okay I think that you but what
makes you think that I'm trying to do
this for myself because I don't give a
[__] I'm gonna take this out I'm all
doing this for some sort of self-benefit
that's why we're talking yeah
putting on YouTube I do this because I
enjoy it though I didn't say that you
two things can be true right yeah you do
this because you enjoy it you also do it
because you make money you also do it
because you get clout you also do it
because you get to express your opinions
sure multiple things can be true okay
right so one thing doesn't override the
other sure what I'm saying is is that if
you were being your truest purest most
authentic self I think you would have
behave differently in the podcast we've
got a different behavior from me I'm not
out here to bully someone who feels like
insecure like I think that's the worst
thing ever I think that if somebody
feels insecure and they're pretending to
be something they're not
you know that's what it is but I think
you need to find yourself a little man
I'm just I'm just trying to figure out
where where this took this turn we're
still talking about you no but where did
they stick this turn off we don't even
have to have the mics on bro
well how about this I mean everyone's
[__] screaming we gotta I think we
gotta wrap up I think we gotta wrap up
but uh I mean I personally had fun I
don't know if you did but I appreciate
it I appreciate Andrew I'm really
impressed with you guys have done on
being this sincerely like genuinely
impressed thank you bro well you're
[__] money we appreciate you thank
you guys very much
on YouTube
yeah man thank you so much
thank you and what you're building is
[__]
you're sharp man thank you bro you're
sharp dude thank you it is cool to see
that yeah let's go with the live stream
Saturday he's doing a live stream
Saturday yeah things come by then you
got to make time now I mean we gotta I'd
love to we gotta make it very steiny
should we yeah is he still invited
listen there's no why don't we continue
the rehab session listens there's
nothing
stop it stop it
stop it about me I got therapy
10 a.m to 6 p.m I got therapy so if what
you just did to me he's cute
[Laughter]
I'd love to have you guys there if you
want to do it man we got to figure out a
time Sammy now make it happen this is
awesome thank you you're a [__] man
it's Friday now I'm gonna message you
guys okay brother thank you okay and
permission YouTube yes
what was that this was definitely
planned you did it for yourself
can you tell me or not I thought you
were [__] with me I don't know during
the Pod there was a moment where I was
like I think this kid is [__] with me
and you know we can play that game bro
everything I do is like a joke you can't
take it too seriously even right now
you're [__] with me I'm not bro I don't
know what to do with this [__] kid it
makes me feel uncomfortable bro I don't
know what it is this is planned this is
planned for sure I couldn't script that
bro I wanted to be boys bro even that is
such a weird thing to say to a man right
how's that one to be bullies like you
wouldn't say that it's amazing you got a
moment bro yeah thanks means a lot man
it's a pleasure thank you so much
thank you thank you of course of course
[Music]
foreign